Julia Louie Dreyfus cancer reveal
everything we know plus a behind the
scenes look at thor ragnarok everyone
I'm Denny direct oh and I'm starting
today with some shocking news from one
of my favorite comedic actors ever Julia
Louie Dreyfus she just revealed today
that she's battling breast cancer Julia
made the announcement on social media
and somehow managed to turn her own
bravery into a moment to speak up for
others she wrote the good news is that I
have the most glorious group of
supportive and caring family and friends
and fantastic insurance through my union
the bad news is that not all women are
so lucky
so let's fight all cancers and make
universal health care a reality you know
we were with Julia just ten days ago
after she won her history-making sixth
Emmy for V Julia found out about her
diagnosis the day after et has also
learned the riders on veep are currently
working on scripts for the final season
but there's no set date for production
to resume obviously we are sending love
and lots of well wishes to jld and her
family but switching gears to another
funny foursome that's right tonight is
the return of Will & Grace and I'm so
freaking excited about it we've been
waiting for this for more than a decade
and let me tell you I went to a recent
taping to the revive show and it is
better than ever so who from the cast
has changed the most
shawn has changed the most because when
we first began he had never done a TV
show just jack just Jack just check out
the cast then and now and seriously
these four have not aged but turns out
Megan recently experienced a case of
mistaken identity I was getting out of
the car at the airport and these two
guys with like giant photographs were
like can we get your honor and it's two
pictures of Julia Louie Dreyfus is only
shame in getting on Clayton 11 years and
nearly 200 episodes later this case has
still got it true confessions I've been
watching them all along on the weekends
time it was Thanksgiving morning we were
sitting there and watching the third in
a row and my kid got up and had looked
at the television we went are you just
gonna watch yourself on TV all day from
JLo to Britney Spears the show has seen
big guest stars who can we expect now
Oprah
Mick Jagger George clean I make you know
that I'm flying the shoe itself is just
like funny on its own I don't know that
we need Taylor Swift to come on or
something
okay but I'm still holding out for Jack
to do the look what you made me do Corey
oh you know I know it Drock I could
teach her huh yep still got it alright
from TV to one of the most anticipated
movies this fall for Ragnarok
Chris Hemsworth is back as the god of
thunder only this time with a short new
haircut well that's not the only thing
that will be different this time around
here is a special behind-the-scenes peek
in this film we wanted to kind of strip
it back and wanted have more fun with it
you know I'm taka had the exact same
idea and we were both saying installed
Ragnarok it's trying to have more
attitude
Ragnarok sort of a new cycle in the
light of the world in all the realms of
the universe it's the destruction of the
old' and the rebirth of the new that's
really exciting to me surprise this will
be such fun the way that I've approached
this is to rebuild it in a new way
look great dude
totally I think it's just perfect mix
for where the character and story need
to go in our different costumes
different weapons different cast or
characters to work or give you a
different energy Thor has been a crisis
he never went back to Asgard to claim
from he wanted adventure when we pick
him up he's at the end of this search
for himself when the ones we survive
this trip I'd say the odds are about a
million to fund
[Music]
you know I wanted to take people on a
ride and and inject some comedy into it
an adventure that keeps people laughing
along the way but also has a spectacle
and the stuff that gets people excited
he's a fighter
it looks good doesn't it I throw a
ragnarok touches down in theaters on
November 3rd now before we sign off we
lost a pioneer in the publishing
industry and an icon of American culture
Playboy founder Hugh Hefner died
peacefully at his home on Wednesday he
was 91 tributes have been pouring out
from fans friends and celebs and we dug
into the et vault and wanted to share
with you Hugh's own thoughts on aging
and death the year was 1998 and now more
poignant than ever age is really only a
number and life is to be celebrated it's
all too short anyway and you know the
great sadness in life is the fact that
we're all mortal and it will come to an
end and I think we should live every
life or every day of every of your life
with great anticipation and a
celebration of the very fact that we're
here and that is you know the blessing
of it all there was one man who lived
his life out fully its mr. Hugh Hefner
we have more on whose life and legacy up
now on ET online.com and while you're
here like comment and share and we will
be back tomorrow with a new music Friday
playlist for you guys we'll see you then